the Iranian regime is clearly scared by
the scale of these protests which are
spreading around the country to every
section of society
groups of lawyers in Tehran the latest
to take to the streets they're chanting
women life and Freedom the signature of
these demonstrations
but there are signs of differences
emerging within the political Elite Ali
larajani an establishment figure and
presidential candidate in an interview
with Iranian media suggesting the
Crackdown may be counterproductive his
statements diverge from the hard line of
Ayatollah Ali kamini the supreme leader
what we can see beyond the surface is
precisely the need for the for the
regime to find a way to save face but at
the same time
um you know
um save itself as well and survive the
challenges that are coming from this
protest movement
the demonstrations began more than four
weeks ago following the death in custody
of this 22 year old Iranian Kurdish
woman Masa amini she'd been arrested by
the morality police for allegedly not
covering her hair properly
[Applause]
the anger at her death has turned into a
protest movement going far beyond the
hijack which women are now burning as an
act of defiance
but the Crackdown in many places has
been predictably brutal videos uploaded
to social media show Security Forces
arresting and beating protesters as they
try to restore order
places it seems they're failing with the
unrest continuing Into the Night
this is the dash where clouds of tear
gas envelop the streets as they shout
anti-regime slogans but there are
reports the city is now under the
control of the protesters
and whilst Talk of the beginning of the
end of the Islamic Republic may be
premature these demonstrations are
unlikely to stop anytime soon and will
remain a significant challenge to the
regime's authority
Alex Rossi Sky News